a little while ago I introduced Donald
O'Connor as a grand old man I'd now like
to introduce a wonderful young sprout
pioneer in the industry and a founder of
the Academy he produced some of the
first great pictures and can't seem to
break the habit because last year he
helped to bring to the screen the great
Caruso and so to present the award for
the best production of 1951 mr. Jesse L
Lasky
you know as I looked over the list of
nominated pitches this afternoon I was
struck with one thing the uniform
excellence of these motion pictures now
as for my private preference well I'd be
just as happy to see this contest end in
a five-way tie but obviously faith must
be more precise and the envelope will
contain no such happy resolution the
nominees for the best production of 1951
are an American in Paris
metro-goldwyn-mayer decision before dawn
20th Century Fox a Place in the Sun
Parma kouvaris metro-goldwyn-mayer and
the streetcar named desire
cows cape Ullman group productions
Warner Brothers the fatal envelope
please oh dear the winner is an American
in Paris
parking decision against American Paris
the best motion picture of
arts and sciences and the award is to be
accepted by Arthur freed who comes again
to the podium thank you and thank you
for my brilliant associates who made
this possible
Vincente Minnelli Gene Kelly and a great
studio with a real courage and
leadership who supported me thank you
came off for the biggest one of them all
there's only one more thing ladies and
gentlemen before we close up shop for
the night
mr. Howe fit the envelope please it says
here there's no business like show
business and there right and now I leave
you in the very capable hands of Johnny
green and his orchestra to dine and
dance to your heart's content good night
ladies
begins to empty the house with their
like show business that ain't it the
truth 3000 people are edging towards the
rear doors of the theater half of them
celebrate with friends who
they do in Brooklyn way till next year
either way the 24th Academy Awards show
is now part of the archives Paul Douglas
saying good night and thank you for
sitting in with us